[Music]
have you ever wondered how it's possible
to scratch
a cd or a dvd and still have it play
back whatever it's storing
the scratch really does affect the ones
and zeroes on the disk
so it reads off different data from what
was stored
but unless it's really scratched up the
bits that it reads off are decoded
into precisely the same file that was
encoded onto it
a bit for bit copy despite all of those
errors
there is a whole pile of mathematical
cleverness that allows us to store data
and just as importantly to transmit data
in a way that's resilient to errors
well okay actually it doesn't take that
much cleverness to come up with a
way to do this any file whether it's a
video or
sound or text some code an image
whatever
is ultimately some sequence of ones and
zeros
and a simple strategy to correct any bit
that gets flipped
would be to store three copies of each
bit
the machine reading this file could
compare these three copies
and always take the best two out of
three whenever there's a discrepancy
but what that means is using two-thirds
of your space for redundancy
and even then for all of that space
given up there's no strong guarantee
about what happens if more than one bit
gets flipped
the much more interesting question is
how to make it so that errors can be
corrected
while giving up as little space as
possible for example using the method
that you'll learn about this video
you could store your data in 256-bit
blocks
where each block uses nine bits nine
to act as a kind of redundancy and the
other 247 bits are free to carry
whatever meaningful message or data that
you want
and it will still be the case that if
any bit gets flipped here
just by looking at this block and
nothing more a machine will be able to
identify
that there was an error and precisely
where it was so that it knows how to
correct it
and honestly that feels like magic and
for this particular scheme
if two bits get flipped the machine will
at least be able to detect that there
were two errors
though it won't know how to fix them
we'll talk a little bit later about how
this scales for blocks with different
sizes
methods that let you correct errors like
this are known reasonably enough
as error correction codes for the better
part of the last century this field has
been a really rich source of
surprisingly deep math
that gets incorporated into devices we
use every day
the goal here is to give you a very
thorough understanding of one of the
earliest examples
known as a hamming code and by the way
the way i'm thinking about the structure
of this video is less about explaining
it as directly as possible
and more a matter of prompting you to
invent it for yourself
with a little gentle guidance here and
there so when you feel like you see
where it's going at some point
take that moment to pause actively
predict what the scheme is going to be
before i tell you
also if you want your understanding to
get down to the hardware level
ben eater has made a video in
conjunction with this one showing you
how to actually implement hamming codes
on breadboards
which is extremely satisfying now you
should know
hamming codes are not as widely used as
more modern codes like the reed solomon
algorithm
but there is a certain magic to the
contrast between just how impossible
this task feels at the start
and how utterly reasonable it seems once
you learn about hamming
the basic principle of error correction
is that in a vast space of all possible
messages only some subset are going to
be considered
valid messages as an analogy think about
correctly spelled words versus
incorrectly spelled words
whenever a valid message gets altered
the receiver is responsible for
correcting what they see
back to the nearest valid neighbor as
you might do with a typo
coming up with a concrete algorithm to
efficiently categorize messages like
this
though takes a certain cleverness
the story begins in the 1940s when a
young richard hamming was working for
bell labs
and some of his work involved using a
very big expensive punch card computer
that he had only limited access to and
the programs he kept putting through it
kept failing
because every now and then a bit would
get misread frustration being the
crucible of invention
he got so fed up that he invented the
world's first error correction code
there are many different ways to frame
hamming codes but as a first pass we're
going to go through it the way that
hamming
himself thought about them let's use an
example that's
simple but not too simple a block of 16
bits
we'll number the positions of these bits
from 0 up to 15.
the actual data that we want to store is
only going to make up 12 of these bits
while four of the positions are going to
be reserved as a kind of redundancy
the word redundant here doesn't simply
mean copy after all those four bits
don't give us enough room to blindly
copy the data
instead they'll need to be a much more
nuanced and clever kind of redundancy
not adding any new information but
adding resilience
you might expect these four special bits
to come nicely packaged together maybe
at the end or something like that
but as you'll see having them sit in
positions which are powers of 2
allows for something that's really
elegant by the end it also might give
you a little hint about how this scales
for larger blocks
also technically it ends up being only
11 bits of data
you'll find there's a mild nuance for
what goes on at position zero
but don't worry about that for now like
any error correction algorithm this will
involve two players
a sender who's responsible for setting
these four special bits
and then a receiver who's responsible
for performing some kind of
check and then correcting the errors of
course the word sender and receiver
really refer to machines or software
that's doing all the checks
and the idea of a message is meant
really broadly to include things like
storage
after all storing data is the same thing
as sending a message just from the past
to the future
instead of from one place to another so
that's the setup but before we can dive
in we need to talk about a related idea
which was fresh on hamming's mind in the
time of his discovery
a method which lets you detect any
single bit errors but not to correct
them
known in the business as a parity check
for a parity check we separate out only
one
single bit that the sender is
responsible for tuning and the rest are
free to carry a message
the only job of this special bit is to
make sure that the total number of ones
in the message is an even number so for
example right now that total number of
ones is seven
that's odd so the sender needs to flip
that special bit to be a one
making the count even but if the block
had already started off with an even
number of ones
then the special bit would have been
kept at a zero this is pretty simple
deceptively simple but it's an
incredibly elegant way to distill the
idea of
change anywhere in a message to be
reflected in a single bit of information
notice if any bit of this message gets
flipped either from 0 to 1 or 1 to 0
it changes the total count of ones from
being even to being odd so if you're the
receiver you look at this message and
you see an odd number of ones
you can know for sure that some error
has occurred
even though you might have no idea where
it was
in the jargon whether a group of bits
has an even or an odd number of ones is
known as its parity
you could also use numbers and say the
parity is zero or one
which is typically more helpful once you
start doing math with the idea
and the special bit that the sender uses
to control the parity is called
the parity bit
and actually we should be clear if the
receiver sees an odd parity
it doesn't necessarily mean there was
just one error there might have been
three errors or
five or any other odd number but they
can know for sure that it wasn't zero on
the other hand if there had been two
errors
or any even number of errors that final
count of ones would still be even
so the receiver can't have full
confidence that an even count
necessarily means the message is
error-free
you might complain that a message which
gets messed up by only two bit flips is
pretty weak
and you would be absolutely right keep
in mind though
there is no method for error detection
or correction
that could give you 100 confidence that
the message you receive
is the one that the sender intended
after all enough random noise could
always change one valid message
into another valid message just by pure
chance
instead the goal is to come up with a
scheme that's robust up to a certain
maximum number of errors
or maybe to reduce the probability of a
false positive like this
parity checks on their own are pretty
weak but by distilling the idea of
change across a full message
down to a single bit what they give us
is a powerful building block for more
sophisticated schemes
for example as hamming was searching for
a way to identify where
an error happened not just that it
happened his key insight was that if you
apply some parity checks not to the full
message
but to certain carefully selected
subsets you can ask a more refined
series of questions
that pin down the location of any single
bit error
the overall feeling is a bit like
playing a game of 20 questions
asking yes or no queries that chop the
space of possibilities in half
for example let's say we do a parity
check just on these eight bits
all of the odd numbered positions then
if an error is detected
it gives the receiver a little more
information about where specifically the
error is
namely that it's in an odd position if
no error is detected
among those eight bits it either means
there's no error at all
or it sits somewhere in the even
positions
you might think that limiting a parity
check to half the bits makes it less
effective
but when it's done in conjunction with
other well-chosen checks
it counter-intuitively gives us
something a lot more powerful
to actually set up that parity check
remember it requires earmarking some
special bit
that has control for the parity of that
full group
here let's just choose position number
one so for the example shown the parity
of these eight bits is currently odd
so the sender is responsible for
toggling that parity bit and now it's
even
this is only one out of four parity
checks that we'll do the second check is
going to be among the eight bits on the
right half of the grid
at least as we've drawn it here this
time we might use position number two as
a parity bit
so these eight bits already have an even
parity and the sender can feel good
leaving that bit number two unchanged
then
on the other end if the receiver checks
the parity of this group
and they find that it's odd they'll know
that the error is somewhere among these
eight bits on the right
otherwise it means either there's no
error or
the error is somewhere on the left half
or i guess there could have been two
errors but for right now we're going to
assume that there's at most one error in
the entire block
things break down completely for more
than that here before we look at the
next two checks
take a moment to think about what these
first two allow us to do when you
consider them together
let's say you detect an error among the
odd columns and
among the right half it necessarily
means the error is somewhere in the last
column
if there was no error in the odd column
but there was one in the right half
well that tells you it's in the second
to last column likewise if there is an
error in the odd columns but not
in the right half you know that it's
somewhere in the second column
and then if neither of those two parity
checks detects anything it means the
only place that an error could be is in
that leftmost column
but it also might simply mean there's no
error at all which is all a rather
belabored way to say
that two parity checks let us pin down
the column
from here you can probably guess what
follows we do basically the same thing
but for the rows
there's going to be a parity check on
the odd rows using position 4 as a
parity bit
so in this example that group already
has an even parity so bit4 would be set
to a zero
and finally there's a parity check on
the bottom two rows using position
eight as a parity bit in this case it
looks like the sender needs to turn that
bit eight on
in order to give the group even parity
just as the first two checks let us pin
down the column
these next two let you pin down the row
as an example
imagine that during the transmission
there's an error at say
position three well this affects the
first parity group and it also affects
the second parity group
so the receiver knows that there's an
error somewhere in that right column
but it doesn't affect the third group
and it doesn't affect the fourth group
and that lets the receiver pinpoint the
error up to the first row
which necessarily means position three
so they can fix the error
you might enjoy taking a moment to
convince yourself that the answers to
these four questions
really will always let you pin down a
specific location no matter where they
turn out to be
in fact the astute among you might even
notice a connection between these
questions and binary counting
and if you do again let me emphasize
pause try for yourself to draw the
connection before i spoil it
[Music]
if you're wondering what happens if a
parody bit itself gets affected
well you can just try it take a moment
to think about how
any error among these four special bits
is going to be tracked down
just like any other with the same group
of four questions
it doesn't really matter since at the
end of the day what we want is to
protect the message bits the error
correction bits are just riding along
but protecting those bits as well is
something that naturally falls out of
the scheme as a byproduct
you might also enjoy anticipating how
this scales
if we used a block of size 256 bits for
example
in order to pin down a location you need
only eight yes or no questions
to binary search your way down to some
specific spot
and remember each question requires
giving up only a single bit to set the
appropriate parity check
some of you may already see it but we'll
talk later about the systematic way to
find what these questions are
in just a minute or two hopefully this
sketch is enough to appreciate the
efficiency of what we're developing here
everything except for those eight
highlighted parity bits can be
whatever you want it to be carrying
whatever message or data you want
the eight bits are redundant in the
sense that they're completely determined
by the rest of the message
but it's in a much smarter way than
simply copying the message as a whole
and still for so little given up you
would be able to identify and fix
any single bit error well almost
okay so the one problem here is that if
none of the four parity checks detect an
error
meaning that the specially selected
subsets of eight bits all have even
parities just like the sender intended
then it either means there was no error
at all or
it narrows us down into position zero
you see with four yes or no questions
we have 16 possible outcomes for our
parity checks
and at first that feels perfect for
pinpointing one out of 16 positions in
the block
but you also need to communicate a 17th
outcome the no error condition
the solution here is actually pretty
simple just forget about that zeroth bit
entirely
so when we do our four parity checks and
we see that they're all even
it unambiguously means that there is no
error
what that means is rather than working
with a 16-bit block
we work with a 15-bit block where 11 of
the bits are free to carry a message and
four of them are there for redundancy
and with that we now have what people in
the business would refer to
as a 1511 hamming code that said
it is nice to have a block size that's a
clean power of two
and there's a clever way that we can
keep that zeroth bit around and get it
to do a little extra work for us
if we use it as a parity bit across the
whole block it lets us actually detect
even though we can't correct
two-bit errors here's how it works after
setting those four special error
correcting bits
we set that zeroth one so that the
parity of the full block is even
just like a normal parity check now if
there's a single bit error
then the parity of the full block
toggles to be odd but we would catch
that anyway thanks to the four error
correcting checks
however if there's two errors then the
overall parity is going to toggle
back to being even but the receiver
would still see that there's been at
least
some error because of what's going on
with those four usual parity checks
so if they notice an even parity overall
but something non-zero happening with
the other checks
it tells them there were at least two
errors isn't that clever
even though we can't correct those two
bit errors just by putting that one
little bothersome zeroth bit back to
work
it lets us detect them this is pretty
standard it's known as an extended
hamming code
technically speaking you now have a full
description of what a hamming code does
at least for the example of a 16-bit
block but i think you'll find it more
satisfying to check your understanding
and solidify everything up to this point
by doing one full example from start to
finish yourself i'll step through it
with you though so
you can check yourself to set up a
message whether that's a literal message
that you're translating over space or
some data that you want to store over
time
the first step is to divide it up into
11-bit chunks
each chunk is going to get packaged into
an error-resistant 16-bit block
so let's take this one as an example and
actually work it out
go ahead actually do it pause and try
putting together this block
okay you ready remember position zero
along with the other powers of two are
reserved for error correction duty
so you start by placing the message bits
in all of the remaining spots
in order you need
this group to have an even parody which
it already does so you should have set
that parity bit in position 1 to be a 0.
the next group starts off with an odd
parity so you should have set its parity
bit to be one
the group after that starts with an odd
parity so again
you should have set its parity bit to
one and the final group
also has an odd parity meaning we set
that bit in position eight to be a one
and then as the final step the full
block now has an even parity
meaning that you can set that bit number
zero the overarching parity bit
to be zero so as this block is sent off
the parity of the four special subsets
and the block as a whole will all be
even or zero
as the second part of the exercise let's
have you play the role of the receiver
of course that would mean you don't
already know what this message is
maybe some of you memorized it but let's
assume that you haven't what i'm gonna
do
is change either zero one or two of the
bits in that block
and then ask you to figure out what it
is that i did so
again pause and try working it out
[Music]
okay so u is the receiver now check the
first parity group and you can see that
it's even
so any error that exists would have to
be in an even column
the next check gives us an odd number
telling us both that there's at least
one error
and narrowing us down into this specific
column
the third check is even chopping down
the possibilities even further
and the last parity check is odd telling
us there's an error somewhere in the
bottom
which by now we can see must be in
position number 10.
what's more the parity of the whole
block is odd
giving us confidence that there was one
flip and not two
if it's three or more all bets are off
after correcting that bit number 10
pulling out the 11 bits that were not
used for correction
gives us the relevant segment of the
original message
which if you rewind and compare is
indeed exactly what we started the
example with
and now that you know how to do all this
by hand i'd like to show you how you can
carry out the core part of all of this
logic
with a single line of python code you
see what i haven't told you yet
is just how elegant this algorithm
really is how simple it is to get a
machine to point to the position of an
error
how to systematically scale it and how
we can frame all of this
as one single operation rather than
multiple separate parity checks
to see what i mean come join me in part
2.
[Music]
you